people have argued that we live in a
post-truth society but there is no such
thing actually as post-truth thinking
truth is fundamental to our to the idea
of thought that that's what thinking is
the attempt to get the true answer to
something so if you if you discard truth
there is nothing left except the pursuit
of power and and I think this is one
thing that students have to confront in
in the humanities this idea that truth
is somehow marginal or negotiable it's
simply something that you use to
embellish your arguments that is
something that is preached by many of
the gurus in particular Michelle
Foucault who was so influential and
still is informing the new curriculum
the new curriculum is not about finding
out the truth of what people have
written but finding the power that
advances behind it so that you can
confront it and be a hero of the left I
have to